if you're thinking about taking an
environmentally sound vacation because
that's most people right now
most people in America are concerned
with their carbon footprint when they
travel is that not true is that not true
is that isn't that why we love cruises
so much because it's an efficient way to
get 3 000 morbidly obese people out into
the middle of the ocean is that not why
we're doing it
but they're at CBS News by the way now
imagine running this story I mean this
is kind of hilarious so CBS News in the
midst of what's going on where we have
one of our presidents is indicted uh one
of our presidents Donald Trump our
ex-president was indicted uh Joe Biden
is going to be uh you know uh you know
perhaps dealing with some stuff about
the purisma the Energy company in the
where Ukraine that's coming out that he
had deals with with him and his son
um we have this real crisis of uh
confidence in our political systems with
our justice department maybe acting
politically uh we have issues all over
the place and CBS has decided that right
now the most important thing to focus on
is uh how much methane gas is being used
on your trip uh in the summer now most a
lot of Americans cannot afford to go on
a trip now of course CBS doesn't cover
that CBS doesn't cover that they don't
cover the fact that there's people that
are lining up in food banks because they
can't and eat uh their children are
going to bed hungry they can't find work
they're living in areas of the country
that we've given up on Rural America we
don't give a [__] Republican Democrat
whoever nobody gives a [__] about any of
these so they're not talking to those
people but they are talking to people I
guess that are going to take a vacation
not only are they going to take a
vacation but they have the luxury of
thinking about how to do it in an
environmentally sound way
CBS News let's watch this right and by
the way when you watch this it is the
most insane segment I have seen in a
very long time from the media and that
tells you something let's watch the good
people at CBS News the Weekender
this summer some people are looking for
ways to take a vacation while also
cutting down on their greenhouse gas
emissions
Market is expected to exceed 331 billion
dollars by 2027 according to new
research data ecotourism can have an
impact on where some people choose to
visit and how they get there let's bring
in tree Minch a features editor for
discover magazine tree let's talk about
some destinations where folks can
actually give back to the planet I love
this by the way I love CBS News to go
they go
is there a way we can do because we're
trying to push this ecotourism thing is
there a way we can do it with a trans
person named tree
is there a way we can do this segment
with a trans person named tree they're
like we have a trans person named Sarah
they go no no we'd like to try and and
no no shade to tree but it's just very
funny and again let's watch some of this
because it is just very funny this idea
that like ecotourism which by the way is
the most loosely defined thing ever it's
just gonna be people go rich people
going to like nice places and they're
gonna go they're just it's ecotourism
they want to lower their carbon
footprint it's glamping and it's like
okay it's not they're not primarily
concerned with their carbon footprint
they want to take Instagram photos in
Montana in a tent but all right let's
see what tree has to say
yeah absolutely so you know this whole
local movement that we've been seeing as
a trend across the country I think that
tourism is an amazing place where it
fits in you know one of the first places
like trees are real mench state parks
and County parks that have a wealth of
opportunities for amazing destinations
to immerse yourself in but also the
money you're spending there the
activities you're doing are typically
directly going back and actually
sustaining that environment right so go
scuba diving that's under a list of uh
guidelines and understanding that
experts and scientists have of watching
what's happening in these ecosystems and
making sure they're balanced and healthy
for everybody that visits as well as all
the creatures and plants that live there
well it's great to know that you can
actually do it locally and not spend a
lot of money to travel but let's say you
do decide to travel what are some of the
activities that you can look forward to
sure I mean the list is pretty much
endless you can really cater your
interest to local and very eco-friendly
destinations I mean one example would be
the ocean in general this is the news by
the way this is the news in the United
States of America they're telling you
you can go to the ocean
this is the news this is CBS News in the
United States of America
CBS News has a a segment with someone
named tree who is sitting in their room
on Zoom telling you that there's
something I don't know if you've heard
of it called the ocean that you can go
to what do they think Americans do on
vacations
that are so ecologically unfriendly that
they don't do every day of their lives
and they're using stock photo they're
using stock photo of a a white woman
here I don't know running her hand on
sugar cane while she walks down like
these stock photos were very interesting
I don't understand what that's supposed
to be but this whole idea of Eco vacate
like what is so they're saying you you
don't have to fly
I guess you don't have to go to theme
parks because they're not eco-friendly
you could go to the ocean okay that's
the bit that's the segment that they're
doing is that an example of an Eco keep
going with this because I'm curious It's
like what are these eco-friendly but
aren't most summer destinations like
lakes and oceans isn't most of it
eco-tourism isn't that where everyone
goes in the [__] summer what the hell
is going on at CBS shout out to
Catherine Herridge though she's been
doing this a long time Catherine
Herridge has been at every network with
that Frozen face full of wrestling like
keep going
um so you know one thing we like to plug
folks into are things like um their
citizen science opportunities all across
the country the great resource for that
is scissistarter.org where essentially
like you want to go to the ocean you
want to see dolphins they're actually
scientists out there who need the help
of everyday citizens who are
experiencing the ocean and maybe wanna
no they don't train for dolphins maybe
they don't need the help of American
citizens actually let's go out into the
ocean and there's a network of
organizations where look it's pauses
from it with them and you're actually is
this they're literally telling people
did scientists need the help of people
to hatch Turtles
and keep monitor Dolphins what are they
doing with all this money I have to now
work as a scientist on my I have a job I
have a [__] job I have to go and
hatch Turtles
first of all Americans are going to eat
the things they find they're all going
into a pot
so this is just the craziest thing ever
you can be a scientist scientists need
your help well they didn't need your
help about the vaccine
they didn't need your help even if you
asked a question like how about you
leave it to the experts but now we're
supposed to [__] finger [__]
offense and hatch Turtles
let's finish this up with the tree it's
happening unfold while you're having an
amazing experience in Paradise often
what are some of the destinations and
activities you should avoid if you're
trying to protect them this is going to
be good
sure yeah so you know it's really going
to depend on what environment you are in
would it be great if he goes emphasizes
having heterosexual sex
[Laughter]
um having or she I don't know what trees
identifying as having heterosexual are
they this thing that uh having
heterosexual sex and having children and
going to church those are the things
that I think are they leave the biggest
carbon footprint
um uh having children in a heterosexual
Bond of marriage and going to church
that christenings
that would just be treat that's what I
go to Parks you go to research
facilities they're going to have a list
of guidelines things as simple as stay
on the trail which might sound kind of
like simple and something that maybe we
our curiosity gets the best of us and we
want to wander off
um potatoes guidelines that have took in
place are actually really Dynamic to
protect the health of the ecosystem that
are there so following the rules and
guidelines that are there now CBS is
using
um a bunch of black people who seem lost
there's a bunch of Africans CBS is now
using stock footage of a bunch of
Africans whose tour bus has overturned
and they're walking around in the bush
in the jungle trying to figure out
I mean can CBS not who is doing the
stock footage over there at CBS
this is crazy
from activities that you're gonna do
when you really hone in on operations
and things that are run by locals who
live in the community work there it's
most likely that the money that they're
receiving is really going to be put back
into the health and the long-term
sustainability of that place for their
Wellness as well as all the things that
live there
um so it's really good to just kind of
follow those those tips there's
something called disaster tourism what
does that look like yes yes yes yes yes
different different kind of applications
you know where where people will kind of
flood into an area you know in response
to sort of a devastating event or
something that happens there to try and
you know help and offer support and
things and that will definitely
um there's situations and circumstances
where that's called before but um sets
it all usually to plug into operations
like the Red Cross operations like no no
they traffic kids what's best is to go
to San Francisco and what because they
have crazy hats like kind of the western
like azuro had almost and they're in the
jazzies and they're on fence uh no thank
you tree's wrong they're all wrong as
always usual you only have to listen to
me thank you that's the reality you just
do disaster tourism actually is tree was
right you do show up you do try to help
um and the response to an event and it's
a collapse of San Francisco disaster
tourism